that's a Subway sandwich bro
[Laughter]
[Music]
and let us all as a collective Community
use our powers of judgment and what did
this guy do just guess he molested
somebody Mafia yeah
he's a molester bro con artist or
masturbating in public oh yeah maybe we
called Mexican restaurants and got free
food
that's dirty that's like the lowest of
low not to my people you jerk oh my god
when you do your voice I picture that
guy which one this guy
it looks like this
God damn that was my football coach some
[ __ ] I tell you something [ __ ] it's
like a second balance in the [ __ ]
alignment coach let me tell you so you
get down you guys grab your cajones
right there or something he put one
right there there you go you hit that
[ __ ] right in the [ __ ] face
I'll tell you that right now if you're
scarier in the wrong goddamn sport get
the hell out of here it's around the
corner son all right
yeah I did cheerleading that's why I
went around the corner continue keep it
going keep it going keep it going great
warm-ups
so this guy is actually a former police
officer even better who retires does his
entire [ __ ] thing he retires and then
a week later he's arrested for dealing
drugs to high school kids that's a good
Market though whoa if you're gonna deal
to anybody it'd probably be high school
kids but do they have money though high
school kids well it depends what kind of
high school true if it's got if it's
those Rich schools because high school
kids aren't buying the best [ __ ]
college and above I mean I guess it
depends right what kind of drug was this
in my mind if it's like a private yeah
true they got money you know you never
know so uh he was arrested in February
2021 after he was seen giving drugs to a
17 year old girl in the parking lot of
high school in Harrington the drugs
which were inside an unmarked
prescription pill bottle and were
intended for the girl's mother included
27 acetaminophen and hydrocodone Hydro
acetaminophen that's Tylenol that is
regular but Hydrocodone pills and three
baggies of fentanyl whoa whoa never mind
oh damn dog what kind of pronounce these
high school who mixes Tylenol and
Fentanyl I would assume it's maybe
putting it in a prescription thing as if
like to not get caught it's not like
he's giving her a baggie of cocaine it's
probably he's giving her a
over-the-counter like here's some
ibuprofen in an Advil box inside is also
Fentanyl and stuff like a true drug
dealer I mean that's what you do when
you travel right you sometimes you have
like random prescriptions and they
allegedly
is just put it in an Advil bottle
because that's easy to carry everybody
understands I don't do drugs I don't
know about you I don't do them I sell
them so when police executed a search
warrant at his home a few days later
they found ansi's 15 guns that had been
reported stolen in Hancock and
Washington counties over the previous
he's a gangster he'd be just taking them
from like evidence room from the [ __ ]
police stations where he stationed at
and stuff it was just that that kind of
entrepreneurial crooked cop you know
what I mean wasn't doing super dirty but
did he lose his job as a cop or did he
return he retired and started selling
drugs to kids yeah that's a good racket
damn they're not paying enough I thought
the cops got paid enough did he have his
own team of like cop drug dealers oh
that'd be cool huh that's a good story
that'll be too hypocritical that's
almost uh what's that what's that movie
American Gangster is that what it is 21
jumps yeah the soldiers he was like
smuggling drugs no but that's still good
that was that was uh what's this
Gladiator Russell Crowe still being a
good guy being overly good but there
were cops that were like taking yeah
yeah and they were pissed at him because
he turned in the money spoiler alert
like every cops that are here I don't
I was retired or he was like a cop that
was like higher up and he was exploiting
like younger women and was like
basically blackmailing them and like
other cops from like that same area saw
what was happening and then they just
ignored it that sounds like every
Department yeah that's the blue Veil
right like uh right or wrong even if you
know that that's wrong you know that
you'll be punished if you [ __ ] say
something so it's not just like oh like
I gotta protect all my cop buddies it's
also like oh if I rat them out I might
get [ __ ] up you know what I mean so
guilty by association a little bit a
little bit but I mean that's why I guess
this guy had the right mindset he was
like after I retire
maybe it makes more sense but I could
only imagine right especially if you
have you know access or you have power
in these restricted areas yeah I want to
figure you'll make money with high
school kids I know right go for you'll
come up like I think you'll just go to
like a you know the neighborhoods that
buy drugs like college kids or some [ __ ]
and I feel like their charges would be
worse because they're minors yeah it's
too risky he knows the law you know what
it has to be dude he's got to have like
an inside connect knowing that like
these kids are buying this type of drug
and he's like oh I can just sell this
[ __ ] maybe his son friends and Shay's
like these [ __ ] do they find
more drugs at his house they found more
guns and stuff
um prior to the February 1st 2021
incident at the high school uh this dude
on multiple occasions allegedly gave
drugs to the girl's mother in exchange
for what police euphemistically
describing court documents as a
non-monetary form of payment
got graphics
sorry dude sorry
[Laughter]
you're doing it
hold it from the back and over
so yeah um apparently she was sucking
his dick I guess
um or something oh that's what that was
no oh guys it's non-monetary form of
payment in his Cruiser that's that's
what it says Yeah official court a long
conversation what if she like cleaned
his Cruiser or something
you know you know that is poor judgment
just because she's a woman Nick that's
not yeah I do I'm trying to think like
things you could have gave him an oil
change yeah yeah oil change
changes spare tire or something you know
you never know what do you what do you
think she did or dick suck yeah yeah
grab your dick suck maybe she baked
um
I don't think she did anything I think
uh he was just hoping that she would I
thought there would be some sort of
incentive nah she did
listen uh he probably had a crush on her
or something right maybe she just
flashed her boobs and then that's it
boring listen not for fentanyl yeah are
you serious maybe maybe for the Advil
yeah Advil will be a little [ __ ] nip
slip but come on nip slip so this is the
same mother that he was giving the drugs
to so it's not technically the team it's
the mom technically and she's the mule
yeah and it's the same person over and
over uh the one that he was originally
kind of caught for prior uh yeah but
where do these people live uh Maine in
uh I know who she voted for son of a
[ __ ]
that was one for your mind just like
wander like who did she vote for whoever
you thought you'd voted for that's what
that's who she was that's the one right
uh previously uh he had worked in law
enforcement in Maine for 25 years before
retiring at the top of 2021 before he
was caught like a month later
um he served as a police officer in
Ellsworth
um who cares about his past history the
fact is he was a cop for his whole
[ __ ] damn career
and uh in 2006 while employed as a
deputy with the Washington County
Sheriff's Department he lost a bid to
the Republican Party nominee for Sheriff
oh he was still trying he was trying to
be [ __ ] Sheriff didn't get that so he
decided to retire [ __ ] [ __ ] so he was
running as a Democrat then yes
Republican party he lost a bid as the
Republican Party nominee oh okay so he
lost a Democrat yeah days after the
primary loss he was seen throwing a
political opponent's campaign sign into
the river later was convicted of
attempted criminal mischief yeah and
find 100 bucks [ __ ] acts like a
[ __ ] fifth grader we didn't get his
weight
that's really funny yeah is there a
footage of that I would love to see that
the sign throwing specifically no I only
have footage of the non-monetary [ __ ] in
the car
oh man that's too bad it's too bad oh
God what a [ __ ] weirdo dude how do
you get to that point as a cop to be
like [ __ ] I'm gonna start selling
drugs he probably just lost his mind
dude there is an interview for a corrupt
cop on soft white underbelly and he
tells his whole story of like how he
slowly became more and more corrupt and
sold drugs and all that [ __ ] it's pretty
[ __ ] wild is it because the system's
[ __ ] convenient for him it's almost
like it's easy it's easy everything's
already there
kind of like like spoiled kids and [ __ ]
that ended up doing like weird things
like [ __ ] torture [ __ ] sex type of
[ __ ] because like they're so bored
because they have everything it's like
serial killers how they say they [ __ ]
with with like animals and cats and [ __ ]
and then they go to humans I'm thinking
about that one innocent ass [ __ ] uh
experiment with kids you remember when
they left like a kid in an empty room
they were like all right don't eat these
Skittles okay and then leave the room
but they have all these cameras on and
then some kids are like yeah stranger
things what no just just in general you
don't talk about these experiences some
kids will be like some kids obviously
grab it some kids wouldn't and stuff
like that but I guess the same thing for
a grown ass cop I don't think cops are
like the craziest intellectuals in my
opinion but who knows it's probably good
um and I imagine same [ __ ] you got
nothing but [ __ ] guns and drugs and
[ __ ] money that's right Dana why not
right there and you see it every day
right and you know 15 years in the
business and you're like I don't get a
great paycheck and you're like yeah and
these drug deals that you're catching
are way more richer than you yeah and
you're just like why I'm doing the good
thing and I don't get I would be a
corrupt cop I'm just letting you 100
corrupt cop that's why I stay out of it
me I'm a good guy what would you be a
girl cop or a good cop 25 years old
corrupt 35 years old good cop corrupt or
a good cop
um maybe good corrupt good corrupt
corrupt
no it turned corrupt oh good turns her
up you can't do it good karate don't put
me in a box
in her defense maybe she's saying you
know I don't want to speak for you but
maybe she's saying some things I would
stay good with and other things I would
be corrupt for is that what you're
saying I don't know if I feel like my
morals won't let me do it then you're a
good cop you're a little too good there
you got like you already I feel like you
will steal it and then you'll be like
you know bring it back sorry I was gonna
take this book
she's like but I should write a report
hi I put this in my bag but you know I'm
sorry I didn't mean to say it honestly
the only thing the only thing I ever
stolen in my life was a pack of gum you
stole a pack of gum how do you feel
about it weird I felt weird
yeah I was like I want some gum and I
just like took it because it was like
right the cash register my parents were
checking out or whatever and I remember
I offered it to my siblings like hey you
want some gum and you're like yeah and I
was like here I'd be like where'd you
get this like I just grabbed it and then
afterwards I was like thinking like
maybe
[Music]
same thing when I was a kid but I got
caught by my mom and she made me go up
to them and tell them that I stole it no
my person I found out but my favorite
thing though was like when they used to
have like gummy bears or candies like
out in the dispensers and you could just
like open it oh yeah scoop it yourself
and you put in a bag I just do all that
I just like yeah I just like to go damn
you guys are [ __ ] thieves you stole
stuff that was free
now you have to share with your brothers
and sisters
I barely get anything out of it my
sister would be like you're hiding a
[ __ ] piece whatever
you go [ __ ] good copper corrupt cop I
think I would start being a good cop and
then I'd eventually probably crack and
then I'd start doing some crazy [ __ ]
I'll probably be a wild boy oh wow boy I
don't know it depends on the context
I'm gonna get technical with you so then
come up with the context okay let's say
okay let's okay all right all right I'ma
[ __ ] tell you something okay let's go
all right we [ __ ] we're in we [ __ ]
kicked the door whatever [ __ ] guns
down guns in place and I'm gonna take
these [ __ ] to the car I'll be
back you see the room full of cash like
this oh cash okay cash
um and your mother needs surgery oh
absolutely I'm taking you made it easy
for her
better get your mama some titties
a little bit of extra just in case it's
a botched job right right okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah take a little extra just
because I need a boob job
so would you take the cash I'm saying
I'm out I'm like I'm gonna go take this
[ __ ] in the car
yeah but you did this so I know you're
in on it no no I'm more like you know
surrounded no you're like get the cash
yeah yeah get the program oh that is
this the Robert get the cash get the
cash go then I'm just gonna be like I'll
be back give me something yeah and then
you just what do you do do you take the
money honestly well I I would think
does the operation know how much money
no we were there to arrest nothing to do
with him okay then um
patreon
I think that's a victimless crime bro
you take cash off a drug dealer because
I could probably do some good with it
like better better than boot drop your
mom absolutely problem solved
not for patreon you it's on the main
channel oh yeah
oh me nah never yeah I'm a good cop good
cop puss my dumbass will try to be like
I'm gonna [ __ ] fix this from the
inside I'm gonna take these crop
[ __ ] out and then like three
months later I'll be like [ __ ] this yeah
dude you gotta face chat and everything
that's good
what about you me okay
call Rod would you would you take would
you take drug ass from the I would
[ __ ] take our thing dude yeah I'll be
the last guy do the drugs dude I'll be
the last guy at the locker room [ __ ]
everybody's like all right see you later
dude later Todd letter dude with money
falling out as he walks okay
you know what I mean everything's
getting jacked dude I'm taking
everything in this [ __ ] we should be
cops let's do it
[Music]
oh
[Music]